bonjour alyssa joue notre nouveau pdg
gysi excusez moi je peux vous poser une
petite question oui bien sûr le monsieur
qui est sous la tablette c'est c'est lé
travail en présentiel
ça permet d'être en adéquation avec
notre nouvelle démarche convivialité en
évitant les risques que les gouttelettes
et tout ça oui je n'aime pas trop les
germes
d'où le body et schering une policière
bones et si c'est vraiment bien mais
c'est bien oui c'est bien on pourrait
même étendre l'idée aux équipes
ah non surtout pas non faut que vous
soyez un maximum 13 ans sur site
1 vous êtes notre image la boîte c'est
vous qui la fait bon je m'explique
qu'est ce qu'on fait ici service de la
data show du pitou pis c'est ça voilà on
s'en fout c'est pas ça qui est important
ce qu'on veut c'est une histoire c'est
celle d'une boîte coule avec des gens
cool les gens pas cool on fait du
footing redynamise on veut de la couleur
on veut du genre les gens qui l'ont bien
dans la lecture on sait pas trop si
c'est des hommes ou des femmes on
pimente et puis quelques normaux aussi
bien sur des femmes des pâtes des pâtes
des pâtes riz des femmes partout des
femmes à tous les niveaux à tous les
étages le vase attention avec des
salaires d'homme parce que sinon ça va
encore être pour notre gueule mais ne
vous inquiétez pas alice va vous
chapeauter un rien
[Rires]